MEANWHILE TO THIS DEMOCRATS
TRYING TO STEAM ROLL JOE BIDEN'S
3.5 CAN TRILLION DOLLARS
SOCIALIST WISH LIST THROUGH THE
HOUSE AND SENATE ALL THIS WEEK.
THEY ARE TRYING TO SELL IT AS A
PLAN FOR THE FUTURE WITH THINGS
THAT REALLY MATTER.
GET A PEN.
LIKE $3 BILLION TOWARDS TREE
EQUITY AND $15 MILLION FOR
SENIOR CITIZENS WITH GENDER
IDENTITY ISSUES.
I SPOKE TO SOUTH CAROLINA
SENATORS TIM SCOTT AND LINDSEY
GRAHAM YESTERDAY AND THEY RAISED
SOME FLAGS AS TO THE DIRECTION
OF THE BILL, LISTEN.
>> BRINGING IN USHERING IN
SOCIALISM IN A WAY THAT'S GOING
TO BE UNRAVEL.
IT'S HARD TO UNSCRAMBLE AN EGG.
WHETHER A THEY'RE DOING WITH
THIS $3.5 TRILLION PACKAGE, THE
CONTENT RUSHES US TOWARDS
SOCIALISM.
>> THIS IS THE BIGGEST THREAT TO
THE WAY OUR GOVERNMENT WORKS AND
BIGGEST STEP TOWARDS SOCIALISM
IN MY LIFETIME.
>> Brian: BUT THE REAL OBSTACLE
IS FACING MAYBE FROM HER OWN
PARTY.
THE DEMOCRATS WHO ARE SKEPTICAL
OF THE PLAN, THEY HAVE SOME
MODERATES AND THOSE WAY TO THE
LEFT.
SO PELOSI DECIDES TO TAKE IT TO
THE MEDIA OVER THE WEEKEND TO
VOICE HERS CONCERNS.
THIS WILL BE PAID FOR.
SO WHEN SOME SAY OH, WELL, WHAT
ABOUT INFLATION?
IT WILL BE PAID FOR.
AND THAT'S THE BEAUTY OF IT.
LET'S NOT TALK ABOUT NUMBERS.
LET'S AND DOLLARS, LET'S TALK
ABOUT VALUES.
>> Brian: OKAY.
I'M SORRY FOR GETTING CAUGHT UP
IN THE TRILLIONS.
IT SOUNDS LIKE EVEN PELOSI
DOESN'T KNOW WHO IS PAYING FOR
ALL OF THIS.
SHE IS MORE CONCERNED ABOUT
VALUES, NOT COSTS.
AREN'T WE ALL?
DON'T WORRY, MS. SPEAKER, BIDEN
SEEMS TO HAVE THE ANSWER IN A
TWEET HE REALLY ASSUAGED ME AND
MAYBE HAVE A SENSATIONAL
AFTERNOON.
HE SAID MY BUILD BACK BETTER
AGENDA COSTS ZERO DOLLARS.
AND IT ADDS ZERO DOLLARS TO THE
NATIONAL DEBT.
WHAT AM I MISSING?
NOW DEMOCRATS ARE IN THE HOUSE
ALREADY PUSHING THROUGH WITH
THIS NARRATIVE LIKE CONGRESSMAN
JAYAPAL, LISTEN TO THIS.
>> PRESIDENT BIDEN ALSO SAID
SOMETHING VERY IMPORTANT THE
OTHER DAY WHICH IS THIS IS A
ZERO DOLLAR BILL BECAUSE IT'S
GOING TO BE COMPLETELY PAID FOR
WITH TAXES.
>> Brian: MY HEAD IS ABOUT TO
EXPLODE.
NOTHING MAKES SENSE ANYMORE.
HERE TO SAVE ME TEXAS
CONGRESSMAN DAN CRENSHAW.
CONGRESSMAN, I DIDN'T KNOW
$3 TRILLION BILL WAS FREE.
>> IT'S NOT FREE.
NOTHING IS FREE, BRIAN, I'M
SORRY BUT I CAN'T GIVE YOU A
GOOD EXPLANATION FOR THIS
BECAUSE THERE ISN'T ONE I WILL
TELL YOU WHAT IT'S WELL ABOVE
$3 TRILLION.
THE NEW ESTIMATES ON IT BASED ON
ACTUALLY GOING THROUGH IT AND
THE BUDGET COMMITTEE ARE ALMOST
$4.5 TRILLION.
AND THERE IS ONLY ABOUT
$2 TRILLION IN TAX INCREASES.
SO, I KNOW MATH IS HARD FOR
DEMOCRATS AND ESPECIALLY SO FOR
THE ONES WHO GOVERN BUT THIS
MATH DOESN'T WORK OUT.
THE OTHER REALLY INTERESTING
THING ABOUT THIS IS THEIR LACK
OF UNDERSTANDING ABOUT BASIC
ECONOMICS.
BIDEN SAYS IT COST ZERO DOLLARS.
THAT'S LIKE WHEN I GO BUY A CUP
OF COFFEE BECAUSE I PAY FOR IT
DOESN'T COST ANYTHING.
OF COURSE IT COSTS SOMETHING.
I THINK WHAT THIS BILL REALLY
BOILS DOWN TO IS STRAIGHT UP
BRIBERY FOR THE PROGRESSIVE
AGENDA, FOR THE PROGRESSIVE
ACTIVISTS AND TRYING TO BRIBE
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
I WILL TELL YOU WHAT, BECAUSE OF
THIS BILL YOU MIGHT NEED THOSE
BRIBES BECAUSE IT'S GOING TO
KILL YOUR JOBS AND WAGES.
IF YOU ARE IN THE ENERGY SECTOR
IT'S AN ESTIMATED 90,000 JOBS
LOST BECAUSE OF THE PROVISIONS
THAT ARE IN THIS BILL AND THE
NATURAL GAS TAX, FOR INSTANCE.
NOT ONLY THAT BUT YOUR LENGTH
PRICES ARE GOING GO UP AS A
RESULT AND YOU ARE NOT GOING TO
HAVE RELIABLE ENERGY LIKE THE
PROBLEMS IN CALIFORNIA AND
FRANKLY THAT'S WHAT LED TO SOME
OF THE PROBLEMS IN TEXAS.
THERE IS A LOT OF BAD STUFF IN
THIS.
THE CORPORATE TAX INCREASE WILL
KILL JOBS.
NOT ONLY THAT BUT ECONOMISTS
ESTIMATE IT WILL ALSO REDUCE
WAGES.
THIS IS BAD ON SO MANY FRONTS
LEAD TO SLOWER GROWTH AND STAGGS
NATION AND INFLATION.
WHICH IS NOT SOMETHING AMERICANS
NEED RIGHT NOW.
>> Brian: THERE ARE TWO BILLS.
1.2 TRILLION THAT WAS HANDED TO
YOU GUYS THAT THE SENATE PASSED
WITH 1 REPUBLICANS VOTING FOR
IT.
SO-CALLED BIPARTISAN BILL.
EVIDENTLY 23 HARD YESES AMONG
REPUBLICANS IN THE HOUSE FOR
THAT.
BUT THERE IS 45 HARD NOS FROM
THE LEFT WING DEMOCRATS.
WHERE IS THE 1.2 TRILLION
BIPARTISAN PLAN AND WHAT DOES
DAN CRENSHAW DO ABOUT THAT?
>> THERE IS A REALLY GOOD POINT
MASSIVE RECONCILIATION PACKAGE
AND THE INFRASTRUCTURE PACKAGE.
THE INFRASTRUCTURE PACKAGE MY
PROBLEM WITH THE INFRASTRUCTURE
PACKAGE IS THAT IT IS SIMPLY TOO
EXPENSIVE.
THE STUFF THAT'S IN THERE ISN'T
THAT BAD BUT I THINK IT'S ABOUT
THREE TIMES MORE EXPENSIVE THAN
IT NEEDS TO BE.
AND, THE GOOD NEWS IS THE
PROGRESSIVES AREN'T GOING TO LET
DEMOCRATS PASS THAT ONE EITHER.
BECAUSE, LOOK, I THINK THE LAST
THING WE NEED AFTER SPENDING
$6 TRILLION OVER THE PAST YEAR
BECAUSE OF CODE RELIEF, IS MORE
SPENDING.
ALL RIGHT.
WE NEED TO REIN IT IN.
DO WHAT WORKS FOR THE ECONOMY.
DO WHAT PROMOTES GROWTH.
WHEN YOU PROMOTE GROWTH
BUSINESSES FLOURISH, THEY ARE
HIRING PEOPLE AND WAGES
INCREASE.
DO YOU KNOW WHERE WAGES HAVE
ESPECIALLY INCREASED FOR THE
BOTTOM COMBINE TILE OF EARNERS,
THAT'S PROVEN UNDER THE TRUMP
ECONOMY.
WE COULD DO IT AGAIN.
AGAIN ALL JOE BIDEN HAD TO DO TO
BE SUCCESSFUL WAS DO NOTHING BUT
HE CAN'T HELP HIMSELF.
>> Brian: THEY ARE GOING TO BE
RAISING TAXES FROM 37 TO 39% ON
THE UPPER CLASS.
GOING TO BE TAKING THE DOUBLING
THE CAPITAL GAINS TAX.
THEY ARE GOING TO TAKE THE
CORPORATE TAX RATE FROM 21% TO
28%, MAYBE EVEN HIGHER.
THEY ARE GOING TO FIND A WAY TO
PAY FOR AT LEAST HALF OF IT WITH
TAX DOLLARS THAT USUALLY GO TO
GROW THE ECONOMY.
CONGRESSMAN, IT'S A SCARY TIME.
I HOPE REPUBLICANS CAN STAND UP
FOR IT BECAUSE IT'S NOT EVEN
ABOUT POLITICS.
IT'S ABOUT THE FUTURE OF THE